hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapter 10 book 1 of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics he engages in a
discussion that for many of us may seem
you know culturally very distant from
where we are and it's a question about
whether the dead are happy or not and
whether their descendants actually
affect that but it's really not quite so
distant if we think about the ways in
which we still behave where we talk
about persons legacy and their interest
in providing for for say their children
or for other people who they considered
to be an important to them so let's
let's see what Aristotle actually says
he picks up with this kind of someone
who was one of these traditional seven
wise men of Greece Solon was actually
quite an interesting person he you know
reform the laws of Athens to the
dissatisfaction of both the rich and the
many which is probably a sign that he
did it the right way but it all started
he's up there he was also involved in
giving advice to variety of people all
around and he gave some advice to King
Croesus which
of course didn't listen to it ends up
becoming a captive of King ever Cyrus of
the Persians Solon said when he was he
asked about happiness he said look to
the end look to the end of the person's
life and only then can you be sure that
they're happy now of course the punch
line is that Croesus himself is
incredibly happy and powerful in his
lifetime within tangles with the wrong
person because he gets an Oracle that he
misinterprets and winds up becoming a
captive and serving Croesus and Persians
the rest of his life losing his kingship
losing a whole bunch of other things in
the process so Solomon is saying this to
Croesus food who doesn't really grasp
the meaning and so on is saying you can
really only judge a person to be happy
and after their life is over and so this
raises some some interesting questions
are we saying at this point that while a
person actually is happy we can't with
any reliability call them happy during
their lifetime but only after their
lifetime has ended or we think their
happiness actually continues on into say
their their state of being dead and
these are some questions that Aristotle
is grappling with so he says that is is
that this is this the case only after a
person has actually lived happily at
virtuously demonstrable aids other
people can't recall that person happy I
mean some people we can probably say our
miserable attorney our lifetime that's a
bit easier to say and perhaps something
that we can say are not miserable but
they're clearly not happy because
they're not you know for Aristotelian
displaying the virtues or cultivating
the virtues they're just you say well
you know watching TV their whole life or
something like that well one of the
people who really are living the good
life
according to Arizona that is a life of
virtuous activity which does include
some external prosperity as well well
can we call them happy during their
lifetime so he's going to
examine that but he's also going to
examine this in terms of whether people
are affected after they're dead by what
happens to their descendants he says
suppose a man to have lived in perfect
happiness until old age and have come to
a correspondingly happy debt so we can
call that person happy according to
Solomon's criteria he may still have
many things befall his descendants some
of whom may be good and meet with the
fortune they deserve right all there it
was the opposite they may be bad and
meet with the fortune that they deserve
moreover these descendants may clearly
stand in every possible degree of
remoteness from the ancestor in question
he says now it would be a strange thing
if the dead man were also to change with
the fortunes of his family that's one
side of the question right if uncle
Ralph was a great guy and gonna live
this wonderful life in which he you know
fed the the poor and you know was a big
brother to everybody and built great you
know wonderful monuments that that
inspired people I'm going to go on and
find the war you know with courage and
live with temperate life even though he
could have indulged himself as much as
he liked to be yeah all the stuff does
it matter what happens to his kids or to
his cousins or to his nieces and nephews
or to his great-great-great
great-great-great grandchildren does
that make a difference in his happiness
now it has a dead person
Arizona says it would be a strange thing
if the dead man were also the change of
the fortunes of his family and were to
become a happy man at one time right
because let's say things go well for the
son he's only got one kid right make it
really simple he's only he's got a son
and things go great for him but the son
he has five kids and all of those kids
get hooked on drugs and wind up fighting
with each other over the inheritance and
squandering at
you know dying early lives so does that
mean that that you know call this guy al
does that mean that he's happy for a
while a certain interval of time and
then he ceases to be happy and becomes
miserable when his grandkids are the
ones on the scene messing things up it
seems kind of weird if we're talking
about the happiness of somebody whose
life is over that they would somehow be
happy or unhappy depending on what other
people's lives are Aristotle then also
says would be a strange thing yet on the
other hand it would also be strange if
the ancestors were not affected at all
even over a limited period by the
fortunes of their descendants and you
might say well maybe Aristotle's just
being superstitious but it does make
sense why why do people think it's so
important to have a riddle to make sure
that there are fears are in order you
know we need to think about it these are
well they're they're concerned about it
in their lifetime because they don't
want to think badly about what might
happen to their poor kids or their their
spouse or whoever else there's some
people put their dogs and cats and in
their pillows you know all these are the
things yes that's true but presumably
the will represents the will of the
person after their daddy so why do they
care at all maybe maybe we don't think
of them as caring at all and we say like
Aristotle does at what point we might
even doubt whether the the debtor can
even feel happiness or unhappiness or be
happy or unhappy but Aristotle does seem
to think that the dead in some sense do
in fact enjoy a happiness or unhappiness
and he says it does make some sense that
the the what happens with those that
you've left behind it doesn't
necessarily just have to be your your
children but also the friends that you
left behind or perhaps if you have a
legacy you know like you did something
for your country or something for your
company something for your your town you
know this is why people want to put
their names on library
and university buildings and hospitals
because they think that that matters for
them and presumably the thing that
they're naming also matters for them as
well a little bit further on aristotle
is going to say that the happiness of
the dead is not influenced at all by the
fortunes of their descendants and
friends in general seems too heartless a
doctrine and contrary to accepted
beliefs so he does think that it plays
some role where he will end up taking
his final position it's sort of a
compromise he will say that the dead are
in fact affected by their descendants
and the happiness or unhappiness that
their descendants experience but not so
much that they go from being happy to
unhappy or unhappy to happy so the dead
have either a state of happiness or
unhappiness and it can be increased a
little bit or decreased but it's not
going to cross that threshold from
happiness into unhappiness or misery or
vice versa so this is kind of an
interesting way of thinking about things
thinking about not just our descendants
but also the legacy that we want to
leave in place so that is Aristotle's
position of us